- Yes!
- Yeah!
- Oh my god.
- We are the best Jews.
(guitar music)
- My name is Sarah,
and I grew up in a
conservative Jewish household.
- I was raised in a Christian
and Jewish household,
so my mom is Jewish,
which makes me Jewish.
- Yes.
- My dad is Christian.
- You're official.
- I feel pretty good,
I went to Hebrew school
for like 13 years.
- I'm slightly nervous for these questions
because I don't want
it to expose a huge gap
in my knowledge about my own religion.
- I'm ready.
I feel like I've been preparing
for this for my entire life.
- Yeah.
- Should we do this?
- Yeah, l'chiam,
let's go.
- L'chiam!
(violin music)
- You know what I mean,
It's not that.
- I think it's like
the Torah, like.
- [Both] Reform,
Conservative, and Orthodox.
- I didn't even need Hebrew school.
- I don't think we count
the guitar hippie reconstructionists.
- I don't know.
- Yeah,
Okay.
- I have no idea.
(violin music)
- [Both] Challah.
- Obviously.
- Challah.
- Yeah. You got to ha when you say it.
Challah.
- Yeah, I feel like I
say it with the "chhh".
- That was an easy one.
- Yeah.
- Come on.
(upbeat violin music)
This is going to make
my mother very proud.
- Um.
- Genesis.
- Numbers is one of them.
- Okay, are they like the bible?
- Exodus.
- There's another one that starts with D.
- Um,
Bartholomew.
- No!
- Leviticus, Numbers,
and then the fifth one.
Moses, No, that's not it.
(upbeat violin music)
- That's all, I got two.
- That's actually really embarrassing.
(upbeat violin music)
- I feel like it's two percent.
- One percent?
- One percent.
- [Sara] I think there's
only like six million of us.
- I knew the number two
was in the percentage,
so we should get points for it.
- Already killing it.
- Thank you, yes.
(upbeat music)
- [Sara] Well, it was
after
World War Two.
- It had something
- 1948.
- to do with Gandhi though like.
- I'm going to go with like the 1880's.
- I feel like it somewhere in Switzerland.
Okay, you know what? I'm just going to say
1945 just in case.
(buzzer)
- [Sam] Okay, I was right
about Switzerland.
- Half right.
- I was right about Switzerland.
(upbeat violin music)
- [Josh] I think it's Syria.
- [Claire] I was going to say
like Lebanon or something.
- I want to say like Turkey?
- I don't know why my
gut was like it's Syria.
- Go with your gut, go with your gut.
- Alright, we're going to go with Germany.
(buzzer)
- Hamantaschen are pretty good
but like if they're Italian food,
I would expect them to be
like a little bit better.
(fast paced music)
- It's at the tip of my tongue.
- Manischewitz.
- How do you not know this?
- Okay, there you go.
- Jewish delicacy.
Finest wine in the world.
- Questions I thought were really easy
I didn't know the answers to,
which was really embarrassing.
- Yeah.
- I'm impressed.
I am so impressed with us.
- Yeah, maybe I didn't ace this quiz
but I still host a Seder every year.
I still am a Jew.
Like who cares?
It's a quiz.
- I'm very proud.
- I've like,
- Yeah.
- My Hebrew school teachers
are very proud of me right now, I hope.
(upbeat music)